finally transpennine Express passengers
have a cancellation they can celebrate
the end of the company's contract to run
Services across the north really
unreliable like I mean all the trains I
travel to Manchester Liverpool quite a
lot and the trains across the north are
just the rubbish they're just rubbish
frustrated I would say because
oftentimes I get to work late and that
doesn't speak well of me it's about a
time but a lot of the companies get
nationalized this is hopefully for me
the first of many after months of
disruption Services between Liverpool
Manchester Leeds and Hull will come
under State Control when its contract
expires at the end of the month
to achieve the performance levels I
expect that passengers deserve and that
the northern economy needs it's clear
that both the contract and the
underlying relationships must be reset
transpennine Express owned by first
group has overseen huge disruption with
up to one in four Services canceled
every day to the frustration of
commuters and fury of Northern Mayors it
has been a catalog of misery people
moving house changing jobs losing
opportunities choosing a different
University because they know they can't
get there not taking up opportunities
for culture because they don't know if
they can get home missing funerals it
has been unacceptable transpennine is
the fourth franchise to come under State
Control reflecting the weakness of a
railway that's effectively been
government run since the pandemic
transparentine Express has a dreadful
record and it's come to symbolize The
Wider failings of the rail network that
sense of national infrastructure just
doesn't work as well as it should and
the gap between transport investment
between North and South which is because
the government's taking over there's no
guarantee it's going to get any better
a failure to recruit and train drivers
compounded by industrial disputes is at
the heart of trans penins problems
Northern business is desperate for a
solution we need a government that's
going to deliver hs2 that's going to
deliver Northern Powerhouse rail across
the penins at the moment we can't even
deliver the limited number of services
we actually could run between our
Northern cities and it just isn't good
enough
this week will end with yet more strikes
across the network affecting Eurovision
among other weekend plans
a good job commuters have learned to be
patient Paul Kelso Sky News in Leeds